cette enquête dont convergent vers la
belgique particulièrement dans la ville
de molenbeek dans la région de bruxelles
devenu une plaque tournante de l'islam
radical alexandra vous êtes donc dans
cette ville ce soir habituellement
tranquille mais qui est devenu depuis
les attentats de paris un centre
d'attention mondiale oui feeling parce
que en fait les deux des huit
participants à ces attaques à paris le
13 novembre dernier les frères abdeslam
étaient des enfants de de molenbeek un
qui est décédé pendant les attaques et
l'autre qui est toujours en fuite saleh
qui est l'homme qui est l'homme le plus
recherché d'europe
et alors que les yeux sont tournés donc
vers molenbeek mais aussi vers la
belgique
on se rend compte que la belgique
fournis par tête d'habitant le plus
grand nombre de djihadistes au sein de
l'état islamique
on se rend compte que effectivement
toute la belgique et surtout bruxelles
et surtout molenbeek un quartier de
bruxelles c'est vraiment là que beaucoup
d'attentes à des dernières années ont
été préparés en partie ou en totalité
oui depuis longtemps donc vous êtes
promenés à molenbeek vous avais parlé à
des gens aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui vous
a le plus frappé
mais ce qui frappe à molenbeek c'est
qu'en fait c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
pouvait s'imaginer avant d arriver c'est
pas du tout une banlieue de paris ou de
lyon ou de marseille vous savez ces
banlieues avec les barres d'immeubles
énorme et des jeunes désoeuvrés qui
traînent dans les rues bon il ya
beaucoup de chômage à molenbeek c'est
sûr mais c'est une ville plutôt
proprette c'est une ville où il ya
beaucoup de femmes voilées ya beaucoup
musulmans surtout des marocains mais
c'est une ville assez tranquille et on
est vraiment étonné de penser que dans
cette ville beaucoup d'attentats ont pu
être préparée au cours des 15 dernières
années ça surprend vraiment c'est ici
qu'a été élevé l'homme le plus recherché
d'europe le huitième terroristes
responsables des attentats de paris
aujourd'hui en fuite salah abdeslam 26
ans son frère bryan 31 ans était aussi
du nombre
mais lui a actionné sa ceinture
d'explosifs
tous les deux ont vécu ici à côté de
cette place sur laquelle les caméras
sont maintenant braqués en permanence où
on se retrouve être saoul et le le
centre du monde terroristes djihadistes
ont l'impression qu'il ya des centres de
formation pour dieu existe ici à
molenbeek comme si la commune de
molenbeek à l'être à jumeler avec rakau
que un bobard daddy
et citoyen d'honneur de molenbeek n'en
est rien samir ben el kaïd père de deux
enfants d'origine marocaine s'occupe de
l'intégration des jeunes au marché du
travail
il n'apprécie pas l'image qu'on donne de
sa ville mais voilà ça va être difficile
de pouvoir pour un jeune postuler un
emploi continue sur son cv il n'est son
adresse à molenbeek
ça va être extrêmement difficile parce
que elle va stigmatiser pendant encore
pendant quelques années
malheureusement ça mirabeau nous montrer
tous les coins agréable de sa ville il
n'arrive pas à faire oublier que les
frères abdeslam ne sont que les derniers
d'une longue liste de djihadistes qui
ont vécu à molenbeek aussi loin que
septembre 2001 les assassins du
commandant massoud
farouche opposant aux talibans en
afghanistan ont été formés à molenbeek
les frères kwasi responsables du
massacre à charlie hebdo à mehdi
coulibaly de celui de l'épicerie cacher
à paris se sont approvisionnés en armes
dans le quartier est le plus important
peut-être abdelhamid about de le cerveau
de l'opération de vendredi 13 et de
plusieurs autres vraisemblablement a
passé presque toute sa vie à molenbeek
c'est probablement de la syrie à
distance qu'il dirige aujourd'hui les
opérations européennes
c'est normal qu'un jeune qui n'a pas de
travail qui vit sous pression qui ne
s'est pas louer d'appartements qui n'a
pas de vie sociale
c'est normal que c'est un terreau
fertile pour tous ces gens qui embrigade
c'est du pain béni pour ces gens là
bombardé de questions par les
journalistes venus du monde entier la
mairesse de molenbeek affirme qu'elle se
bat depuis longtemps déjà pour qu'on
consacre plus de moyens à la lutte
contre la radicalisation
le phénomène du radicalisme il existe
depuis longtemps
mais c'est vrai que les autorités
politiques policiers n'ont pas
suffisamment pris la mesure du danger et
donc on a cru que c'était un phénomène
qui n'aurait pas d'impact sur la
belgique sur l'europe
le réveil est brutal les habitants
commencent à s'habituer à cette descente
de police à la recherche d'armes ou
d'hommes ici alexandra schatz qu'à
radio-canada à molenbeek en belgique